this is a woman from Southern
Pennsylvania who's facing multiple
counts of aggravated animal cruelty
torturing and killing animals and
filming herself doing it and uploading
the videos to her YouTube
channel pretty psycho stuff her name is
Anar Mony she's 28 years old authorities
have accused her of producing and
distributing at least four videos
involving the killing of frogs a rabbit
a pigeon and a chicken she was arrested
on Friday and charged with 4 counts of
of aggravated cruelty to
animals really awful story huh how can
we punish a woman for this when we
permit abortion if instead of torturing
and killing puppies she had tortured and
killed a baby in her womb she would not
be prosecuted she would be hailed as a
hero of women's rights and
Liberation so are we saying puppies
matter more than babies puppies matter
animals more matter more than human
beings that is what we're saying but
it's completely incoherent